hey what is up guys I'm Ken Bhd here and
right now I ate all of my videos on one
of these I think it's time to give an
upgrade a shot this is the main gear
shift computer or the mkbhd Edition main
gear shift and these are my first
impressions of it now I actually wanted
to wait till I had a little more space
in a new place to set it up and actually
hook it up to my main setup but I
couldn't really resist getting out the
box and checking it out first so the
main gear shift is essentially a custom
pre-built computer to spec so you pick
all the parts to pick all the specs and
then the guys that main gear put it
together for you but it is a little more
impressive than just that because anyone
can put together a computer as we know
it's not that impossible to build a
machine yourself but it is pretty hard
to build a machine that looks like this
so I plan on giving it a shot as the
main brains of my setup and using it
full-time basically so this is just the
first video I'm making on a couple of
videos that I plan on making about the
experience with this computer as they
happen so this first one is just a first
impressions video maybe let me know what
you guys are thinking you want to see in
the other videos in the comments section
below whether it's exploring the video
editing prowess of a machine like this
or gaming I'm sure is something that
people want to see I don't gain much but
I can try stuff out or maybe it's just
dropping Windows 10 on this guy and
seeing how it compares to the Mac Pro
that I've used for a while now something
you've probably noticed by now if you've
seen a lot of computers with an open
side before is the layout of this case
is a little bit rotated versus your
normal computer layout your ports are
not on the front and they're not on the
back they're all on the top so of course
you do have a little pop-up section here
to give you access to normal some
frequently access ports but taking off
the sides will explain this a little bit
better the entire inside of the main
gear shift is rotated 90 degrees
compared to a normal computer so the
motherboard the graphics cards
everything is turned sideways so the
machine takes in cool air from the
bottom and the side and pushes hot air
out the top and so since hot air rises
that process is helped out naturally by
physics and it's more efficient and it
puts all of your ports now on the top of
the computer so you don't have to reach
around the back anymore if you want to
unplug something or plug something in
and there are a ton of port
you can see by this board 12 USB ports
on the top here alone
most of them USB 3 and the graphics
cards will do multiple outputs as well
so the specs since I know that's a
curious easy thing to just go down the
list and tell you guys what's inside
this machine inside it's rockin an Asus
x99 deluxe motherboard and Intel Core i7
59 60 X so an octa-core CPU overclock to
4.5 gigahertz so 4.5 gigahertz at 8
cores 32 gigs of Corsair ddr4 Ram should
be really fast and to nvidia geforce
980ti also an 800 60 watt modular power
supply down here in the bottom and 3 256
gig SSDs in raid zero for insane speed
plus a 4 terabyte internal drive for
storage so that's a pretty dope list of
specs but there are still the
differences between building that set of
specs for yourself in your own computer
versus buying this main gear built
computer first of all a paint job like
no other this is a custom case and the
red and black and white paint everywhere
is super high quality and it's applied
believe it or not with the same process
as a car is painted so actually when he
took it out the box it had a faint sort
of new car smell with that fresh paint
and the logo on the side is of course
also custom that's what really
solidifies it as an mkbhd edition
version of the main gear shift and
that's the kind of thing that would take
many hours of work in an off-the-shelf
case if you want to do something like
that
also since the professional builds it
cable management from the gods of custom
pcs I mean this is beautifully done
cable ties in all the right places the
modular power supply and everything
sitting neat and tidy
tucked away where it should be and also
allows for maximum airflow it's
beautiful inside you also get a couple
of other things like this binder which
has a build log and a checklist of the
55 point inspection it passed to even
get shipped to you a signature and the
contact info of your builder and even
proof that it passed an overnight burnin
tests and a few benchmarks spoiler alert
this thing drops nearly 32,000 points on
Geekbench 64-bit multi-core it's kind of
a boss so this thing is legit from top
to bottom even has a little multicolored
LED light strip on the inside by the
window with a remote control so you can
control all the way the lights look
without ever
opening up the case and all these sorts
of things all the things the little
things that make the main gearshift
different from something that you would
build yourself will be explored in
future videos so can you build something
like this for less technically since
these are mostly off-the-shelf parts
yeah you could get that done but it will
look nothing like the shift so thanks
for watching this video number one of my
experience with this PC and stay tuned
for video number two and all the other
stuff come to this channel thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys the
next one peace